il y a deux manières de voir l'Iran il y
a celle qui consiste à analyser la
politique menée par le chat avec ses
côtés positifs l'expansion économique le
développement industriel mais aussi avec
ces aspects négatifs le refus des
libertés ou bien l'omniprésence d'une
police politique très sévère et puis il
y a aussi la méthode touristique là
également il y a deux méthodes celle du
touriste à faible budget qui se contente
des petits hôtels et qui est donc en
contact plus direct avec la population
ou bien celle du touriste sans souci
pour ces derniers le souverain iranien
vient de créer un petit paradis le ciel
est généralement bleu la mer assez
chaude et les palaces fourmille et l'on
peut même y perdre un peu d'argent au
casino ce nouveau paradis pour Jean
fortuné c'est l'île de quiche c'est il a
été inauguré en décembre et Patrick
Poivre d'Arvor ainsi Christian iru ont
voulu voir à quoi ressemblait l'Iran des
milliardaires
sur ce petit bout d'îles perdu dans le
Golf Persique cinq chaînes de télévision
dont deux programmes entièrement
fabriqués pour et par quiche il y a 5
ans ici il n'y avait que des pierres des
bergers et des moutons sans km² de semis
désert aujourd'hui à grand renfort de
dollars on y fait pousser du gazon pour
un golf qui n'en est encore qu'à son
premier trou et pour pousser il faut de
l'eau là encore il suffit d'une pompe à
pétrole cela donne c'est tubulures à la
Beaubourg c'est une usine de
désalinisation des Arabes y travaillent
qui sous la direction d'ingénieur
israélien tout cela pour quelques
centaines de privilégiés déversés deux
fois par mois par un Concorde infecté de
Paris sur un aéroport construit tout
exprès pour lui
d'avoir une a pas besoin de visa une île
qui soit
libre enfin comment dire sans taxe où
tout est détaxé avec à 20 minutes de
Dubaï à 10 minutes de Bahreïn à une
demi-heure de 1h de rien une heure et
demie de rillade je crois 1h30 de
Téhéran les gens qui veulent discuter
peuvent venir ici dans un bon hôtel et
tous leurs affaires d'un seul coup en
même temps que sont au soleil
pour l'instant ils ne sont encore qu'une
poignée bien protégée bien dorée sur
fond d'or noir dans ce détroit dormeuse
il passe 10 pétroliers par heure l'île
et stratégique c'est aussi une base
militaire mais les touristes ne le
savent pas le chat il y a un palais le
petit prince aussi le même en réduction
la chabanou est la seule à avoir le
droit de se déplacer dans l'île à moto
avec ses gardes du corps ou en voiture
électrique mais n'allez pas lui parler
de snobisme de ghetto de luxe c'est
paraît-il tout bénéfice pour l'économie
iranienne
aux habitants de cette île bien sûr
parce que le progrès qui arrive dans une
minute où les gens vivaient que
simplement des petits commerces et de la
Pêche bien sûr ça va les aider à
améliorer leur niveau de vie comme cela
déjà fait et s'il y a des gens qui vous
font le reproche de dire c'est trop de
luxe au milieu d'un pays qui reste un
pays en voie de développement qu'est-ce
que vous leur répondez
cela répondrais que bon c'est un endroit
de luxe pour que les gens qui aient de
l'argent puissent venir dépenser leur
argent ici et c'est pour ça que nous
avons créé ce complexe et l'argent que
les gens vont dépenser va être au
bénéfice du pays bien sûr
et du luxe il y en a revendre les plus
grands couturiers parisiens s'y sont
déplacés pas de pharmacie pas d'épicerie
dans l'île mais les grands noms de la
couture de l'orfèvrerie de la
bijoux ça c'est la griffe française on
va chercher à l'étranger ce qu'il y a de
mieux de plus chic résultat les chèques
Arabes et les princes d'Iran se sont
arrachés des villas à 1000 dollars le
mètre carré c'est-à-dire toute équipée
sans à 150 millions de francs autour
d'un bon buffet à la française on espère
bien qu'ils seront traités des affaires
et que les Occidentaux pourront enfin
rencontrer les rois du pétrole paraît-il
insaisissable sinon et bien il reste le
casino avec des croupiers qui sont des
croupières et anglaises ce sont dit-on
les meilleurs on a bien prévu aussi un
terrain de polo mais il faut déjà
construire des box à air conditionné
pour les chevaux bref comme on dit ce
n'est pas vraiment à la portée de tout
le monde mais si c'est bon pour les
affaires
bonnes vacances je ne